IN RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT PUBLIC
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING A FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE STATE SENATE HAS MADE IT
NECESSARY TO A BIT NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INTO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW IT WILL BE
USING  TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN IT ALL MELTS NOW-
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR THAT'S EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. THE ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT
THREE ONE FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHAT
WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
ASSIGNED TO THIS NUMBER. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE ON WHICH YOU ARE
WATCHING PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM IN THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT.
TODAY MEMBERS AND PUBLIC WE
HAVE THREE BILLS ON THE AGENDA.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION ON
THE BILL ALSO TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. DODD UP HERE DOT HERE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HERE ALLEN.
ALLEN HERE ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA.
HERE ARE YOU HERE. ARCHULETA
HERE BAKER. BAKER HERE PRESENT
BORDERS HERE BRADFORD GLAZER.
GLAZER HERE WEST SO. WESO HERE
JONES. KAMLAGER MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ HERE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO HERE RUBIO WILK.
WELL HERE GENERALLY HAVE A FORM-
THE SECRETARY NOTES QUORUM IS
BEEN ESTABLISH MEMBERS WILL BE
MOVING TO THE AGENDA AND FILE
ORDER AFTER EACH BILLS
PRESENTED WILL PLACE A DOG CALL
AFTER ALL THE BILL'S BEEN HEARD
I WILL OPEN THE ROLL CALL ON
EACH BILL ONCE AGAIN TO GIVE
MEMBERS WHO WERE IN OTHER
COMMITTEES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE ON TODAY'S BILLS. OKAY NOW
LET'S HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR CENTER MCGUIRE YOU MAY
BEGIN WITH FILE NUMBER ONE. SB
THREE FORTY ONE. MORNING. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING TO BE HERE TODAY
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS. FIRST OF
ALL I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR- THE CHAIR HAS
BEEN- COLLABORATIVE AS WE MOVED
FORWARD ON THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU TO YOU IN YOUR
FANTASTIC STAFF. FOR THE
DELIBERATION AND DISCUSSION
RELATING TO THIS BILL I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ALONG WITH SENATORS GLAZER
NIELSEN FOR THE PARTNERSHIP
LAST COUPLE OFFICE. I'LL GET
RIGHT INTO IT MISTER CHAIR AND
HERE'S WHAT THREE FORTY ONE
DOES. NUMBER ONE IT PROVIDES UP
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
EXPLICIT AUTHORITY TO CREATE
BACKUP POWER RULES FOR CELL
TOWERS. LAND MINE OPERATIONS IN
CABLE PHONE SYSTEMS NUMBER TWO
IT MANDATES THE STATE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES SHARES THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY ALREADY
RECEIVE FROM TELECOM COMPANIES
ON OUTAGES. TO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION THE REASON
WHY IN THIS BILL THAT SAT AND
WHY THE STATE IS CRITICAL THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION WHO
OVERSEES TELECOMS. AND CREATES
POLICY FOR TELECOMS DOESN'T
HAVE THE STATUTORY ABILITY TO
SEE THIS INFORMATION CURRENTLY.
IN THIS IS WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
DURING TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
PLAN POWER OUTAGE TO BUCKLE AT
ITS PEAK NEARLY TWO MILLION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
ADELINE NINES LANDLINE. CELL
PHONE AND CABLE SERVICE
INTERRUPTED IN THE OUR PHONES
OUR PHONES NOW ARE A LIFELINE
TO TELL WE KEEP IN TOUCH WITH
THE REST OF THE WORLD AND HOW
WE RECEIVE EMERGENCY ALERTS.
YET UP UNTIL LAST YEAR OUR
CURRENT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEM IS A MANDATED TO HAVE A
BACKUP POWER AND I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE CENTER GLAZER FOR HIS
WORK. ON THAT- THROUGHOUT THESE
CHALLENGING EVENTS OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION HAVE TAKEN
STEPS TO MAKE SURE OUR
TELECOMMUNICATION NETWORKS HERE
IN THE GOLDEN STATE ARE MORE
RESILIENT. AND THAT WE KNOW
WHEN THEY ARE WORKING BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHEN THEY ARE NOT.
THE CPC HAS RECENTLY ADOPTED
DECISIONS WIRELESS IN JULY
TWENTY TWENTY WIRELINE FEBRUARY
THIS YEAR ORDER IN
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS TO
DEVELOP COMPREHENSIVE
RESILIENCY PLANS. TO ENSURE
NETWORK POLICE ARE ABLE. TO
MAINTAIN SERVICE TO CUSTOMERS
DURING THE DISASTER. FOR A
POWER OUTAGE. INCLUDING PS
SEVEN SEVEN HOURS. INTERIOR TO
THREE FIRE AREA. WE'VE TAKEN A
MAIN SINCE ENERGY COMMITTEE TO
CLARIFY THAT THIS BILL WILL NOT
AND THE AND- THE RECENTLY
CREATED BACK UP POWER RULES AT
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. OR UPSET THOSE TO
PROCEEDINGS THAT I JUST
MENTIONED. TELCO COMPANIES HAVE
BEEN INCREDIBLY CONCERNED AT
THIS BILL WOULD. SET THE
CURRENT BACKUP POWER
PROCEEDINGS AND I HEAR THEM ON
THAT ASSURE THEIR CONCERN IN
THAT IT'S NEVER BEEN OUR
INTENTION. THE END AND WE WILL
BE MORE THAN WILLING TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS. IF THESE CONCERNS
STILL PROCESS BECAUSE THAT'S
NOT THAT'S NOT WHERE WE WANT TO
GO. A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
RESEARCH HERE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. SB SIX SEVENTY THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES TO
SUBMIT. AN OUTAGENOTIFICATION
TO- YES WHENEVER AN OUTAGE
OCCURS IN THAT LIMITS THE
ABILITY AND THAT LIMITS ABILITY
MAKE NINE ONE ONE CALLS OR
RECEIVE EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATIONS. THIS CRUCIAL
INFORMATION REGARDING WHEN
THERE HAS BEEN A FAILURE IN THE
NETWORK. THE ONLY BE SHARED
WITH LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS LIKE COUNTY- YES
INSURANCE DEPARTMENTS SO THOSE
LOCAL EMERGENCY AUTHORITIES NOR
OUTAGES THAT PUT THE PUBLIC AT
RISK. OUR CURRENT BY THE
STATUTORILY CAN'T SHARE THAT
INFORMATION WITH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WHO IS THE.
REGULATOR OF TELECOMS. WE ARE
EMERGENCY TO NOT A THE STATUE
OF TO SHOW THAT IN. WITH THE
CPUC. CPC'S WITH KEEPING
NETWORKS UP. CHARGE OF KEEPING
THEM RUNNING AND MAKING THEM
MORE RESILIENT BUT THEY DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO WHERE OUTAGES
KEEP OCCURRING. CANDIDLY THAT'S
KIND OF CRAZY. THIS OUTAGE
INFORMATION IS VITAL FOR
UNDERSTANDING WHERE WEAKNESSES
ARE TELECOMMUNICATION NETWORKS
EXIST. IF AN OUTAGE OCCURS IN
MERRY REPEATEDLY. THE C. P. C.
NEEDS TO DETERMINE WHY THIS IS
HAPPENING AND HOW TO PRISON
PREVENT FUTURE OUTAGES WITHOUT
THIS INFORMATION THE PC MUST
RELY ON STAFF INITIATED A
REQUEST. TO TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES TO LEARN ABOUT SOME
FAILURES- YES ALREADY IS
NOTIFIED ABOUT. THIS BILL
CHANGES THAT. ENSURES THAT THE
DATA THAT THE- STATE YES HAS.
SHARED WITH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. CURRENTLY
ONCE- YEAH TO RECEIVE STAMP ON
A TELE. OUTAGE WHICH IS SIXTY
MINUTES OF THE OUTER DISCOVERY
THEY CAN THEN SEND IT ON TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
IT'S ALREADY IN THE DATABASE SO
WE'RE NOT CREATING ADDITIONAL
RULES. SIMPLY ALLOWING PC TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK INTO THAT DATABASE
SB THREE FORTY ONE WILL
STRENGTHEN THEIR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
TELECOMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. REQUIRING YES
TO SHARE OUR INFORMATION WITH
THE PC AND REQUIRES A PC TO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
ACTION AND THEY'VE TAKEN ON THE
VERY STRATEGIES. FINALLY I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO GO OVER SOME
CLAIMS. THAT CURRENTLY ARE OUT
THERE AND JUST MAKING SURE THAT
WE CLARIFY THAT NAY FOR HIS
FACT NUMBER ONE. THIS BILL
PROVIDES PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION EXPLICIT AUTHORITY
TO CREATE BACKUP POWER RULES
FOR T. CELL TOWERS- LANDLINE
OPERATIONS IN CABLE PHONE
SYSTEMS. THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
NOT ALL SOME THAT HAVE CLAIMED
THAT WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO THROW
OUT THE BRAND NEW BACKUP POWER
RULES. AGAIN WE TOOK AMENDMENTS
IN ENERGY AND I CAN'T SAY THIS
AGAIN WE'RE MORE THAN WILLING
TO TAKE ADDITIONAL CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS. THAT WERE NOT HERE
TO. SET THOSE PROCEEDINGS. THE
STRONG BACKUP FOR POWER RULES
THAT EXIST TODAY AT THE PC WILL
STAY IN PLACE IN THE
UNAFFECTED. BY THIS BILL. THIS
IS A FACT. THIS BILL WILL ALSO
HELP THE STATE IF THE
TELECOMMUNICATION INDUSTRY EVER
LITIGATE SEES ROLES CHALLENGING
THE FACT THAT THE PC HAS
EXPLICIT AUTHORITY. TO ENACT
BACKUP POWER RULES AND
REGULATIONS THIS BILL GIVES AN
EXPLICIT AUTHORITY. WE'RE ALSO
PUTTING IN STATUTE TO SIT UP
STRAIGHT IN THE RULES FROM ANY
FEDERAL PREEMPTION CLAIM THAT
SHOULD EVER BE A HOSTILE
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION. LASTLY SB THREE
FORTY ONE WILL ALSO REQUIRE A
WE HAS TO CREATE RULES ON
OUTAGE MAPS. FOR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS
REQUIRE THE PROVIDERS TO ABIDE
BY THOSE RULES ENSURING THAT
THERE'S CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE
BOARD SO WHENEVER YOU ARE A
CABLE CUSTOMER OR WYOMING
CUSTOMER. YOU CAN RECEIVE
SIMILAR PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
BASIC INFORMATION ABOUT OUTAGES
AFFECTING YOUR COMMUNITY. IT'S
A COMMON SENSE BILL I KNOW THAT
THERE'S CONCERNS. AND YOU KNOW
WHAT I WILL CONTINUE TO DO I
WILL CONTINUE TO MEET WITH
INDUSTRY. CONTINUE TO MEET WITH
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICIALS I DID
IT LAST WEEK I WILL CONTINUE TO
DO IT IN THE WEEKS AHEAD YOU
HAVE MY WORD ON THAT. AND THIS
BILL INSURERS AND PROVIDERS IN
THE CPC OR DOING WHAT THEY NEED
TO DO TO IMPROVE THE STATE'S.
NINE ONE ONE NETWORKS AND TO
ASSURE THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO
THE CRUCIAL INFORMATION ABOUT
OUTAGES ACROSS THE GOLDEN
STATE. TODAY MISTER CHAIR- I'M
GRATEFUL TO BE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES ONE THIS IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
COURCELLES SETTLES WITH US. AS
WELL AS DANCE THE FINAL HE'S
FIRE CHIEF FOR THE CITY COSTA
MESA HE'S ALSO THE PRESIDENT A
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WHO SUPPORTS THIS
BILL THE LEAD CALIFORNIA
CITIES. ALSO SUPPORTS A STONER
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR WORK THAT
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN
AYE VOTE AT THE PERFECT TIME
RESEARCHER. THANK YOU SENATOR.
WELL NOW- MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTING TO SPECIFIED SUPPORT
DURING CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LAKE THE HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING FOR PROTOCOLS WERE TO
TRY AND I'D SAY TRY TO LIMIT
THESE FIRST- COMMENTS TO THREE
MINUTES I KNOW THAT THIS IS
MORE TECHNICAL IN NATURE SO I'M
GONNA GIVE SOME LEEWAY- TO THE-
TO THE INITIAL FIRST TWO
WITNESSES. SO- WITH THAT- AND
THEN I'M IN IT WILL ELEVEN
DEBATE FOR THE ENTIRE TO TEND
TO TIRE. DEBATE TO TEN MINUTES
UPPERSIDE. SENATE MCGUIRE I
BELIEVE- DANIEL STEFANO IN
KOREA AS ALSO SO ALSO ARE ON
THE COASTLINE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE PROCEED. I
GUESS MR STEFANO ARE YOU ON-
YES SIR YES GOOD MORNING ON A
REALTOR DOT. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU CENTER
REQUIRE MY NAME IS DAN STEFANO
FIRE CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF
COSTA MESA. AT PRESENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION- THE DISASTERS AND
POWER SHUT OFFS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE SHOWN THAT THE
EMERGENCY TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEMS NEEDS TO BE IMPROVED
BOTH FOR RESIDENTS. AND FIRST
RESPONDERS. SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY ONE WILL IMPROVE OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS BY
CREATING STRONGER OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS.
AND THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WHEN IT
COMES TO TELECOMMUNICATION
OUTAGES AND BACK UP POWER
SYSTEMS AS WELL AS MORE
EFFECTIVE SHARING OF COMMUNITY
ISOLATION OUTAGE INFORMATION.
WHETHER WE LOOK TO THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN NORTH BAY FIRESTORMS
INCLUDING THE TUBBS FIRE IN
SANTA ROSA FOR THE THOMAS FIRE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
DEVASTATING BUT IT DIDN'T
DEBRIS FLOWS THAT FOLLOWED IN
MODEST SETO IN EARLY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE CAN REFERENCE THE
CAMPFIRE TWENTY EIGHTEEN. OR
THE WALLS HE FIRED THE STARTED
LATER THAT DAY AND CUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OR EVEN MORE
RECENTLY- DOWN HERE IN ORANGE
COUNTY THE SILVERADO AND
BONFIRES. IN LATE TWENTY TWENTY
AND SUBSEQUENT MOTHER DEBRIS
FLOWS THAT FOLLOWED JUST MONTHS
AGO- THESE ARE ALL VISITED
EXAMPLES TO DEMONSTRATE GETTING
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE SAFELY
EVACUATED IN THE EARLY HOURS OF
A DISASTER. CLEARLY ELEVATES
THE DEFINING LINE BETWEEN
CASUALTIES LIFE AND DEATH. THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE RESIDENTS
AT ALL OF OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
NEED AND HAVE COME TO EXPECT IT
RIGHT WE SHOULD EXPECT THAT OUR
PHONES WILL WORK WHEN DISASTER
STRIKES. KEEPING THIS ALL IN
PERSPECTIVE SMALLER OUTAGES
OCCUR IN OUR IN OUR REPORTED-
YES DEMONSTRATING WEAKNESSES IN
OUR EMERGENCY COMMUNICATION
SYSTEM. BUT THE CPUC HAS NO
IDEA WHEN THEY ARE OCCURRING.
THE CPUC REGULATES THE
TELECOMMUNICATION NETWORKS AND
REQUIRES THEM TO HAVE BACK UP
POWER BUT IF TELCOS REPORT
OUTAGES OF THE NETWORK STILL
YES THE C. PCA. IS ABLE TO FIND
OUT OF THAT OUTAGE OCCURRED. SB
THREE FORTY ONE WILL RECTIFY
THIS AND WILL IMPROVE OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS. SB
THREE FORTY ONE REQUIRES- YS
TO SHARE COMMUNITY ISOLATION
ALLERGY INFORMATION WITH THE
CPUC AND REQUIRES THE CPUC TO
REPORT THE LEGISLATURE ON
ACTION TAKEN. USING THE
COMMUNITY ISOLATION OUTAGE
INFORMATION. IN CLOSING I WANT
TO THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME ON
THIS CONSIDERATION. FOR THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB
THREE FORTY ONE AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY IT
IS APPRECIATED THANK YOU MR
FADO- IS ALSO- ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. YES MISTER CHAIR PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORY SO ZILLOW
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL HAVING
ACCESS TO INFORMATION ABOUT
NINE ONE ONE OUT AGES IS VITAL
NOT ONLY TO THE PUBLIC BUT ALSO
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FIRST
RESPONDERS BOWSTRING OUTAGE MAP
REQUIREMENTS WILL MAKE THIS
IMPORTANT INFORMATION MORE
ACCESSIBLE WILL IMPROVE PUBLIC
SAFETY. ADDITIONALLY ENSURING
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS APPROPRIATE
BACKUP ELECTRICAL SUPPLY TO
ADDRESS OUTAGES IS IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE CUSTOMERS CAN
COMMUNICATE ESPECIALLY IN TIMES
OF DISASTER AND FIRST
pDOING THEIR VITAL WORK. SB
THREE FORTY ONE ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE BY REQUIRING THE PCM
CALLOW YES TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT BACKUP ELECTRICITY
RULES FOR THE REASONS SHE HAS
TO SAY IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB.
THREE FORTY ONE. THANKS MISTER
SALSOUL- NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE. I WOULD GO
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. SEEING NONE
AS WELL THAT WILL MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU'D
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FORTY ONE WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FORTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
NOW. ONE AND THEN ZERO YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FORTY ONE.
AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF
LINE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES HELLO MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCY NUMBER
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANNEX OF THE LINE OF
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CAN YOU PLEASE SHARE IT ON
BEHALF OF THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK TURN IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS JOHN KENNEDY WITH A RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB THREE FORTY ONE
TODAY WE THINK IT HELPS TO
REINFORCE. THE VIEWS THE
RESILIENCY CENTER TESTED AIM IN
THE ORGANIZATION PLEASE AND
YOUR SUPPORT. NEXT WEEK- MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR-
OKAY HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW UP
THE SAME PROCESS TO HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY YES WE
DO. PLEASE PROCEED. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS EARNING A ROSTER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
HERE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE. THAT THIS MEASURE
IS DUPLICATIVE OF EXISTING
OUTAGE REPORTS AND ALL IT WOULD
DO IS COMPROMISE TO EXISTING
ACTIONS RECENTLY TAKEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE PC. SO IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS REQUIRED A
MENTION THAT SB SIX SEVENTY WAS
ADOPTED AND IS NOW IN PLACE SO
SINCE JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY. IN SUPPORT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY. ATION SERVICE PROVIDERS
MUST REPORT ALL AVERAGES TO THE
CAL- YES HELLO YES THEN IN TURN
MUST SUPPORT REMOTE SUPPORT AND
SHARE THAT INFORMATION. WITH P.
SAPS AND WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC IS PROTECTED.
SO THAT'S ALREADY COVERED SO
IT'S NICE TO HEAR THE PUBLIC
SAFETY FOLKS SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE BUT THAT HAS
BEEN THE LOSSES JERRY ONE.
TWENTY TWENTY. WHAT WAS ALSO
INCLUDED IN THAT MEASURE WAS A
CONFIDENTIALITY. VERSION THAT
INFORMATION IS ABOUT CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT TO BE
SHARED WITH THE PUBLIC. THIS
BILL WOULD UNDO THAT PROVISION
UNDO THAT COMPROMISE THAT WAS
ADOPTED IN SB SIX SEVENTY. AND
NOW SHARE CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION WITH THE PUBLIC. IT
WAS ALSO DONE WAS THE PC ON
FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE RECENTLY ADOPTED NEW
GUIDELINES FOR COMMUNICATION
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO REPORT
OUTAGES TO THE PUBLIC. THAT IS
ALREADY LAW WE MUST PROVIDE THE
CLUB THE PUBLIC WITH AN OUTAGE
MAP WHENEVER WE HAVE. OUTAGES
THAT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THE
PUBLIC SO THAT INFORMATION IS
ALSO BEING SHARED WITH THE
PUBLIC ALREADY TODAY THAT IS
ALREADY THE LAW THIS BILL WAS
INTRODUCED ON FEBRUARY NINTH
THE PC DECISION WAS ADOPTED ON
FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH. THE STATE
TO BE BLOOD THE DAYS IF THIS
BILL IS A DAY LATE AND A DOLLAR
SHORT IN ADDITION. THIS BILL
WOULD CODIFY A PC RECENT
DECISION AGAIN ON FEBRUARY
EIGHTEENTH THAT REQUIRES US TO
HAVE SEVENTY TWO HOURS OF
BACKUP POWER AND SO THAT'S
ALREADY CURRENT LAW TODAY. THAT
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS OF THAT
ARE GOING TO BE HARD TO MEET
WITHIN EIGHT MONTHS WHICH ONLY
HAS SIX MONTHS LEFT WE MUST
HAVE SEVEN TO EIGHT HOURS A
BACKUP POWER. IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO THAT'S ALREADY A PART OF THE
BILL TODAY ALL YOU WOULD DO IN
ADOPTING THIS BILL. IS AGREE
WITH THAT DO YOU SEE DECISION
ON FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH I'M NOT
SURE MANY OF YOU KNOW WHAT'S IN
THAT DECISION. BUT VOTING FOR
THIS BILL TODAY WOULD BE YOUR
ACQUIESCES TO WHAT WAS DONE
THEN SO SORRY IT'S HARD TO BE
WITH THIS PAST. AND SO WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIR- CCJ OPPOSED.
OKAY THANK YOU OF HAVING A HARD
TIME READING THEIR I WOULD JUST
ADD ONE LAST PROVISION IT TO
THE TO THE ISSUE OF PREEMPTION.
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF THE PC
DECISION. A COMMUNICATION
SERVICE PROVIDER WANTS TO
LEGALLY CHALLENGE THAT DECISION
YOU MUST DO SO WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS. SO TO THIS ARGUMENT ABOUT
THIS IS TO ENSURE THAT THE PC
HAS HIS STORY TO DO WHAT THEY
ALREADY DID ON FEBRUARY
EIGHTEENTH. IS NOT VALID-
PREEMPTION MUST BE DONE WITHIN
MUST BE CHALLENGE WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS OF THAT DECISION OTHERWISE
YOU HAVE NO STANDING IN COURT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
THESE REASONS THE CABLE
INDUSTRY IS OPPOSED. ANYBODY
NOBODY ELSE UP ABOVE ANYBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WISHING. TO
TESTIFY THE SEEING NOBODY- NOW
WILL MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE FORTY ONE. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE NOT POSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIND FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN DO YOU
HAVE IT ON MUTE. HELLO. ONE
FORTY ONE. OKAY WE'LLMOVE ON
TO THE NEXT LINE OF WINE THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DO YOU HAVE A TIME YOU. WELL
THE LINE OF BY TWENTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS A
YOUNG WOMAN ON BEHALF OF
CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS- IN
STRONG OPPOSITION IF YOU LOOK
AT THE THREE FORTY ONE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO THE LINE
OF LINE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A RESEARCHER AND MEMBERS
OF THE JONATHAN ERA BELL ON
BEHALF OF CTIA THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE WIRELESS
COMMUNICATION INDUSTRY- AND WE
OPPOSE SB THREE FOUR ONE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND AGAIN WRE
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FORTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND OUR NEXT LINE WILL
COME FROM NINE FORTY TWO. A
LINE IS OPEN. HE MAKES ALL OF
ON BEHALF OF FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BUT LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS THROUGHOUT THE
EVENT THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WILL GO TO A LINE
OF FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS ONE CALCHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR- NOW WE'RE GONNA-
TURN THIS BACK OVER TO- THE
MEMBERS SEE IF THERE'S ANY
DISCUSSION HERE ON THE FLOOR TO
ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I SEE-
CENTER PORTANTINO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- THANK YOU- TO
THE AUTHOR- WE HAD SET EXCHANGE
SOME ROBUST THE- QUESTIONS ANY
PROVIDE A LOT OF ANSWERS I JUST
IF HE COULD IN HIS CLOSER AS A
QUESTION JUST. TO CLARIFY OR
COMMENT ON THE- THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER THIS IS A DUPLICATIVE
EFFORT WHETHER YOU KNOW Y. Y.
E. X. THE NEED FOR THE
EXPANSION OF DATA COLLECTION IS
WARRANTED. BASED ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING CURRENTLY IF HE COULD
pALSO TOUCH UPON THE PROPRIETARY
NATURE OF THE INFORMATION AND-
IF THERE ARE SAFEGUARDS IN
PLACE SO. THAT INFORMATION WILL
GET MISUSED IF HE COULD EITHER
COVER THOSE TWO ISSUES AND IT'S
CLOSE THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
SENATE MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR IN THANK YU
MR PORTANTINO FOR THE ABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK AND FORTH
LEADING INTO TODAY'S HEARING
AND VERY VERY GRATEFUL FOR READ
THAT ROBUST QUESTIONING THOUGHT
ACTIVE AT A TALK ABOUT THE PC'S
ROLAND I TO TALK ABOUT- YES
IT'S REAL FIRST AND FOREMOST
YEAH. WE PASSED SENATE BILL SIX
SEVENTY BECAUSE UP UNTIL. LAST
YEAR FIFTY OFFICIALS LOCAL YES
MANAGERS COUNTY CITIES DIDN'T
KNOW WHEN THERE WAS AN OUTAGE.
THE ONLY REASON THEY FOUND OUT
THERE IS OUTAGES WHEN THE NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM WENT DOWN WHEN
FOLKS PICKED UP THE PHONE THEY
CAN CALL NINE ONE ONE. SO SIX
SEVENTY. PROVIDED THE DATA. TO
LOCAL SHERIFF'S OFFICE. AS WELL
AS OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES
THE COUNTY LEVEL. WITH THAT
DATA. OUR LIVE PERSON TO TALK
TO ME ABOUT WHEN THE
RESTORATION. OF THAT AVERAGE
WOULD OCCUR. IN OUR NECK OF THE
WOODS IN MANY PARTS REAL
CALIFORNIA. ALLERGIES COULD
LAST DAYS DAYS WE WOULD NOT
KNOW WHY WHEN THERE IS
RESTORATION THERE'S A STEP TO
DO THIS NOW THAT DATA THAT IS
PROVIDED TO THE STATE- YES WHO
THEN GIVES IT TO LOCAL- YES AND
IT IS CONFIDENTIAL. THAT DATA
IS NOT SHARED WITH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. SO I GOT
TO BE CANDID WITH YOU IT'S NOT.
DOUBLING THE EFFORTS TO GIVING
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
WHO IS CHARGED WITH OVERSEEING
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES THE
ABILITY TO SEE THAT DATA TO
MAKE THE NECESSARY FIXES TO
KEEP THE STATE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM. UP
RUNNING RESILIENCE. THAT'S IT.
IT'S FROM THE SAME DATABASE
THAT ONLY HAS ALREADY HAS BUT
BY STATE LAW THE PC CANNOT SEE
THAT INFORMATION THEY'RE FLYING
BLIND THEY'RE FLYING BLIND. SO
I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE
CONFIDENTIALITY IS THAT'S BEEN
AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP
IN THIS BILL IN THE BILL IN
AGAIN YOU KNOW ME I'M MORE THAN
WILLING TO TAKE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS ON THIS. SB THREE
FORTY ONE KEEPS THE
INFORMATION. PROVIDED IN SB SIX
SEVENTY CONFIDENTIAL- SO SB SIX
SEVENTY AGAIN PROVIDED A
LIMITATION OF THE PUBLIC'S
ABILITY TO REQUEST CALLOW YESS
OUTAGE DATA- FROM THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT SIMILARLY IN THIS
BILL TODAY RIGHT NOW. THERE IS
A LIMITATION ON THE PUBLIC'S
ABILITY TO REQUEST DATA
PROVIDED CONFIDENTIALLY TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION BY
COMPANIES. OR THE PUBLIC
THROUGH THE P. R. A. BECAUSE
THE P. C. CODE FIVE EIGHTY
THREE. SO WHAT THAT SAYS IS
THAT ANY INFORMATION WOULD BE
PROTECTED ON THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE FIVE EIGHTY
THREE. IT'S ON IT YOU CANNOT
HEAR IT. STILL REMAINS
CONFIDENTIAL IT'S THE SAME
PROTECTIONS THAT'S CURRENTLY IN
SIX SIX SEVENTY THAT IS BEING
TRANSFERRED OVER TO THIS
CURRENT BILL. SO LOOK I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S CONCERN
FROM INDUSTRY I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU. CTIA I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO CABLE FOR
CONTINUED TO ENGAGE IN WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO ENGAGE. BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS. AS FIRE
SEASON APPROACHES. WE HAVE TO
BE A LAW THE PEOPLE WE WORK FOR
IN THE HIGH IN THE AIR TO SAY
THAT WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO BE TO KEEP OUR NETWORKS
UP AND RUNNING. IN RIGHT NOW
THERE IS A GIANT LOOPHOLE THE
REGULATOR OF TELECOM IN THE
STATE DOESN'T GET THE OUTAGE
DATA. WE DON'T GET IT. SO AND
APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
DON'T KNOW THE FOR TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS AND SECURING THANK YOU
MISTER PORTANTINO. THANK YOU
CENTER MCGUIRE SENATOR ALAN.
THANK YOU DID YOU CENTER
MCGUIRE FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
OBVIOUSLY AN IMPORTANT ISSUE- I
HATE I GUESS MY SO MY CONCERN
HERE IS. THIS DEFAULT TO DIESEL
AND YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND YOUR
BILL SAYS THAT THERE'S NOTHING
THAT- YOU KNOW PREVENTS. THE
OUR TELECOM PARTNERS FROM
DEFAULTING TO DIESEL OR OR
SORRY SORRY NOTHING THAT
PREVENTS THEM FROM USING CLEAN
TECHNOLOGIES BUT THERE'S ALSO
NOTHING IN HERE THAT REQUIRES.
CONSIDERATION OF SUCH
TECHNOLOGIES. YOU KNOW WE'VE
SEEN. ONLY OF COURSE IS DIESEL-
VERY POLLUTING- BUT IT ALSO
WE'VE ALSO SEEN THE DURING FIRE
EVENTS DIESEL FUEL TRANSPORT
CAN BE A REALLY MAJOR RISK AS
WELL. NOT BECAUSE OF COURSE
IT'S SO FLAMMABLE. AND WE'VE
SEEN AND WE'VE SEEN FROM OUR
MILITARY AS WELL THE USE OF
SOLAR BATTERIES FUEL CELLS AT
CENTER THAT CAN BE A LOT MORE
RELIABLE FOR HARD TO REACH
SITES. AND I GUESS I SO MY
QUESTION HERE I KNOW THAT WHEN
CENTER DODD WORKED ON A SIMILAR
BILL WITH SB TEN NINETY NINE-
THEY THEY TOOK AN AMENDMENT
THAT AT LEAST ENCOURAGED.
MOVEMENT IN THAT DIRECTION I
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW THE
ARGUMENT THAT THERE'S NOTHING
IN THE BILL. TO PRECLUDE BUT
THERE'S ALSO DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
ANYTHING IN THE BILL TO
ENCOURAGE. MOVE IN THIS
DIRECTION AND I IT REALLY IT'S
A CONCERN THAT I HAVE- AS I
CONSIDER THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH I CENTER ALLEN AT FOR
THAT LOOK. BUT BE CANDID WE
HAVE BEEN VERY CAREFUL WALKING
THE LINE NOT TO UPSET THE
CURRENT PROCEEDING. AS YOU
HEARD TODAY THAT IS A VERY
SENSITIVE TOPIC. SO IN THE
CURRENT PROCEEDING BOTH FOR
LANDLINE AS WELL CELL PHONE-
DAVE TALKED ABOUT THE TYPE OF
BACKUP POWER. IN THAT
PROCEEDING- THE CPC ALLOWS.
TELCOS TO BE ABLE TO USE DIESEL
IN THE SHORT TERM BUT THE CPC
ALSO DIRECTS TELCOS TO USE
CLEAN BACKUP TECHNOLOGY WHEN
REASONABLE. AND THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE AND JUST BEING
VERY BLUNT IN TRANSPARENT
CENTER ALLEN- THIS BILL IS
AGNOSTIC ON THE TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT AT TELCOS WOULD
NEED TO BE ABLE TO DEPLOY. BUT
WE ARE VERY CAREFUL NOT TO STEP
OUR TOTAL INTO THAT PROCEEDING.
AND UPSET THE WORK TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION IS
DOING BECAUSE THAT IS NOT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL- BUT- HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THIS- BUT I JUST WANT TO BE
TRANSPARENT ON WHY. WE DON'T
HAVE THE SPECIFICS BECAUSE IF
WE ARE TO. FOCUS ON THIS. IT
WOULD UPSET THE PROCEEDING ON
WHERE THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION CURRENTLY IS AT.
OKAY I MEAN I GUESS. SO WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE PEACE SO CAN YOU
GIVE US A BETTER SENSE OF WHERE
OF THE CURRENT STATE OF THAT
DISCUSSION OF THE PCM I GUESS
MY CONCERN IS HERE YOUR- YOU
ARE PROACTIVELY ASKING.
EVERYBODY TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT THESE BACKUP. WHAT
PROVIDING STATUTORY AUTHORITY
FOR A COUPLE FULL NUMBER ONE.
THAT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION HAS THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO OVERSEE AND
REGULATE. TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES HERE AND BACK UP
POWER RULES. NUMBER TWO TO
INSURE THAT THEY GET THE DATA.
THAT IS CURRENTLY BEING
COLLECTED FROM OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES THEY GET THAT DATA TO
BE ABLE TO HELP WITH THE
RESILIENCY OF THE SYSTEM.
CURRENTLY AT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION IN THE
PROCEEDING AND I'LL QUOTE FROM
IT. THE PROPOSAL DIRECTS
PROVIDERS UTILIZE CLEAN ENERGY
BACKUP POWER OPTIONS AS
REASONABLE BEFORE USING DIESEL
GENERATIONS. TO MEET THE BACKUP
POWER REQUIREMENT AMONG OTHER
PRETTY. ARE CHANNELED. IN
YOU'VE HEARD THIS TREMENDOUS I
THINK OF YOU- IS. THEY'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT US. PUTTING OUR
TOTAL INTO THE CURRENT
PROCEEDING SETTING THE CURRENT
PROCEEDING OR NEW. OUTSIDE OF
THE PROCESS. SO IF WE WERE TO
GO IN FOR ON. THE ISSUE DIESEL
VERSUS CLEAN WE THEN- START.
SITTING NEXT. IN WHAT I SAY TO
EACH EVERYONE OF YOU HERE TODAY
IS THAT WE'RE NOT THIS BILL
WILL NOT TOUCH THE CURRENT
PROCEEDING. SO THE PRESSURE
POINT AND I DON'T NOT AT ALL
TRYING TO PASS THE BUCK. IT'S
GOING TO NEED TO BE THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ON THIS
ISSUE OR THEIR NEED TO BE
SEPARATE LEGISLATION ON THAT
BECAUSE THIS BILL WE CANNOT
BECAUSE OF THE DELICATE BALANCE
INTO CONCERNS YOU'RE HEARING
FROM INDUSTRY. THE DATE BEEN
ENGAGING A PROCEEDING IN TRYING
TO BE ABLE TO GET THIS THING
MOVING- WE JUST CAN'T UPSET
THAT COURTESY IN THE PC YEAH I
HEAR YOU I'M OF COURSE BUT
WE'RE STEPPING IN WITH THIS
BILL RIGHT I MEAN TO THIS BILL
IS. IS TAKING A PROACTIVE STEP
IN INCREASING THE REQUIREMENTS
ON THE TELECOMS IT'S NOT. AND I
DON'T HAVE ANY CONTROL OVER THE
PC WHEN IT COMES TO SETTING
STRONGER STANDARDS. SO. THERE'S
NO OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO. IN
ANY BY THE WAY THE YOU SEE DOES
REALLY HAVE A RESPONSE. IN THE
AREA I MEAN THERE THEY'RE THEIR
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES AND-
HE'S IN- AND- MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS TO THE
POWER THEY NEED SO. WELL THIS
IS WHAT THE BILL DOES THAT ALSO
THIS BILL GIVES THEM THE
GRANTED STATUTORY AUTHORITY
WHICH THEY BELIEVE THEY ALREADY
HAVE BY THE WAY OVER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND IT GIVES
IN THE CLEAR STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO MANDATE
BACKUP POWER RULES THE REASON
WHY THAT IS NAMED MANDATE NEEDS
AND IT IS. BY THIS LEGISLATURE
IS IN CASE THAT THERE IS
LITIGATION SINCE THEY DO NOT
HAVE THAT AUTHORITY BUT AGAIN I
JUST WANNA BE CLEAR AND I'M NOT
AT ALL TURN THE ARGUMENTATIVE
AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
SENATOR ALAN CENTER ALLEN HAS
BEEN A CHAMPION ON THIS ISSUE.
I INTEND NO B. S. ON THIS- WE
JUST CAN'T WE'RE NOT STEPPING
INTO THE PROCEEDING- WE ARE
AREN'T INCREASING REQUIREMENTS
FOUR NINE DECREASING
REQUIREMENTS WE'RE SIMPLY
SAYING THAT THEY HAVE THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY AND TO BE
TO GET THEM THE DATA THEY NEED
TO BE A TO CREATE. A MORE
RESILIENT AND SAFE AT WORK. SO
I. IF YOU DON'T MIND I'M A
FOLLOW UP ON CENTER ALLEN'S-
QUESTIONING SO OF TO ONE OF THE
THINGS I'VE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION CENTER MCGUIRE IS
THAT- IT REQUIRES THE CPUC TO
ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT A SEVENTY
TWO HOUR POT. BACKUP POWER
REQUIREMENTS WHICH MEANS LARGE
DIESEL GENERATORS IN ALL AREAS
OF THE STATE INCLUDING FIFTH
DISCO LOS ANGELES THE OTHER
URBAN AREAS NOT JUST THE HIGHER
THREAT DISTRICTS. THE CPC IS.
DEVELOPING THEIR CRITERIA ON A
TIER TWO AND THREE HIGH FIRE
THREAT AREAS MAYBE THAT'S ONE
WAY OF GETTING OUT I I'M NOT I
I'D LIKE YOU TO RESPOND TO THAT
DANGER HAVE YOU. HAD THAT
AMENDED. OUT OF THE BILL ARE
YOU STILL REQUIRING THAT FOR
THE ENTIRE STAY BECAUSE THAT
MAY BE ONE OF THE WAYS TO LIMIT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS AND
NOT DO IT FOR THE ENTIRE STATE
JUST TO TIER TWO AND- THREE BUT
ALL THE TIME. THAT THEY DON'T
RESPOND IT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION SECURE THANK YOU- OUR
LANGUAGE IS A GNOSTIC ON THE
TEARS- WE'RE SIMPLY SAYING THAT
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO CREATE
BACKUP POWER RULES. FOR
AGNOSTIC ON THE TEARS CURRENTLY
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
IS A CONNECTOR TO TIER THREE.
AND WE WILL BE MORE THAN
WILLING TO CLARIFY THAT THIS
BILL DOESN'T UPSET THE CURRENT
PROCEEDINGS. WITH OR WITHOUT
THIS BILL. WITH OR WITHOUT THE
BILL THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION COULD GO AFTER TIER
ONE FIFTY ONE INTO RIGHT NOW.
THIS BILL DOES NOT TOUCH THE
PROCEEDING IT DOESN'T TOUCH THE
TEARS THAT THEY WANT TO FOCUS
ON AND RIGHT NOW THEY'RE JUST
FOCUSING ON TIER TWO TIER THREE-
NOW- HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO. TAKE
AGAIN CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS IT
DOESN'T TOUCH PROCEEDING.
THAT'S THE SAME REASON AS WHAT
SENATOR ALLEN IS DISCUSSING
ABOUT THE CLEAN ENERGY. WE ARE
NOT GOING TO TOUCH THE SPECIFIC
TEARS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT HERE TO
BE OF ABSENT THAT PROCEEDING IN
THE WORK THAT'S GONE INTO THAT
DECISION. THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION THANK YOU IS
CENTER LASER BICA. PLEASE
PROCEED. THE EX MISTRESS OF THE
THANK- CARE DOT- I TO LIVE THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS GREAT LEADERSHIP
IN THIS AREA- HE'S BEEN AT IT
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND HAS
DIED DOWN AT THE MICRO LEVEL.
TO SO MANY OF THESE ISSUES THAT
HAVE CREATED GREAT. ANGST IN
TROUBLE. AND FOR A LOT OF OUR
RESIDENTS AND I APPRECIATE-
CENTER MCGUIRE YOUR LEADERSHIP.
IT IS ARGUMENTATIVE BILLS TOO
MODEST- THAT AS YOU HAVE WORK
TO TRY TO WEED THROUGH ALL THE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS OUT THERE
AND THE POWER THAT DOESN'T WANT
TO BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT FOR
THE POWER ISSUES- DEAD DEAD
DEAD IS A BILL IS BEEN TRIMMED
DOWN TO A VERY MODEST PLACE AND
YOU'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR ABOUT
HOW YOU'VE TRIED TO STRADDLE
LOT OF THESE ISSUES AND I
COMPLIMENT YOU ON IT BUT-
THERE'S AN ARGUMENT THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE DEFERRING TO THE
PC. ON THESE MATTERS. THIS IS
ABOUT LEGISLATING. NOT
REGULATING AND WE SHOULD
LEGISLATE. BUT THIS BILL IN
THIS AUTHOR HAS TRIED TO BLOCK
THIS FINE LINE AND SHOW
DEFERENCE TO THE PC AND THEIR
ENGAGEMENT WHICH WE APPRECIATE.
HI ANYTHING TO BE ABLE TO DO IT
IN A WAY THAT HAS- OFFENDED THE
POWER OUT THERE- THAT HAS
SOMEHOW STOPPED US FROM
LEGISLATING IN THIS AREA. AND
IT'S WORTH NOTING. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO SAY THAT WE'VE FACED
THIS DEBATE ABOUT THE TYPE OF
POWER AND ENERGY THAT'S USED AS
BACK UP AND I APPRECIATE. THE
GREAT ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP
FROM THE SENATOR FROM SANTA
MONICA ON THIS ISSUE AND IT HAS
COME UP IN A NUMBER OF PLACES.
BUT THIS ISN'T THE PLACE TO
HAVE THAT DEBATE. THAT THAT'S
THE SENATOR AND OTHERS ARE
WELCOME TO ENGAGE IN THOSE
REQUIREMENTS IF THEY SO WISH
AND TO PUT A BILL BEFORE THE
SENATE- THAT. PROVIDES CLARITY
AS THEY SEE IT FOR HOW THAT
SHOULD BE DONE AND THEY'RE
WELCOME TO DO THAT. BUT THE
BURDEN THIS BILL AND THESE
MODEST REFORMS WITH THAT
ARGUMENT TO ME IS UNFAIR. AND
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT.
THESE ARE VERY STRESSFUL TIMES
FOR OUR RESIDENTS OUT THERE.
AND THEY EXPECT AND DEPEND UPON
US TO PROTECT THEIR INTERESTS.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SYSTEM IS WORKING AND WHAT THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO DO IS
IDENTIFY PLACES WHERE IT'S NOT
WORKING STEP IN THE BREACH DO
OUR JOBS RESPONSIBLY TO ENSURE
THAT HAPPENS CENTER MCGUIRE
COMPLEMENT YOU I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND MOVE THE
BUILT THE APPROPRIATE TIME AS
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZERS **** CENTER JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANTED TO- CAN JST TAG ALONG
ON THE CONCERNS THAT YOU HAD.
REGARDING THE TEARS AND- SOME
OTHER DESCRIPTIONS IT HAPPENED
TODAY. I KNOW SIR MCGUIRE IS
CONTINUING WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS I'M NOT GONNA
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. BUT
HOPEFULLY- IN APPROPRIATIONS
ARE ON THE FLOOR. I'LL BE ABLE
TO CHANGE MY VOTE SO I
APPRECIATE THE DEBATE TODAY
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
IT- TO ADDRESS THE BY CENTER
ALAN FONG I'M GONNA SUPPORT MY
COLLEAGUE AND I YOU KNOW I
FIRST OF ALL I DON'T. THINK
I'VE SHOWN. THE TICKET
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA I JUST
WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS- I DO
WANT TO WORK WITH YOU MOVING
FORWARD ON ON SOME OF THESE
ISSUES I YOU KNOW. I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
AROUND AT ALL. STILL COURSE THE
PUBLIC LOOKS TO US TO LOOK OUT
FOR THEIR THEIR NEEDS AND
CONCERNS BOTH IN TERMS OF- PER
YOU KNOW MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE ADEQUATE RESPONSE.
ADEQUATE SERVICE AND ALSO- HAD
CLEAN AIR SO WE'VE GOT
RESPONSIBILITIES ON MONDAY
VARIOUS LEVELS AND MAYBE THIS
IS IN THE RIGHT PLACE TO. TO TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS ON THE ISSUES
THAT I RAISED- THOUGH I DO. AND
WE ARE WEIGHING IN ON ON
REQUIRING BACKUP POWER AND I
THINK WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE'RE BEING CAREFUL THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST ENCOURAGING MORE
AND MORE. EASILY HOUSTON IN
THESE SITUATIONS WHEN THERE ARE
BETTER ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE
BOTH BETTER FOR ENVIRONMENT AND
ALSO AT THE SAME TIME SAFER-
WHEN YOU GET INTO THE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
DIESEL- MOVEMENT IN AND IN
DISASTER SITUATIONS SO MAYBE
THIS IS IN THE RIGHT PLACE TO.
INJECT THAT ISSUE INTO THE
CONVERSATION BUT. I THINK IT'S
SOME IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE GOT
TO. I WITH THAT I'M CERTAIN
PREPARED SUPPORT MY COLLEAGUES
WORK WITHIN THE SYSTEM IS FOR.
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN SENATE
WHY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A CHAIR.
PERSON FOR MY SISTER I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU FOR THIS ROBUST
DISCUSSION IN CONVERSATION
ABOUT. THIS CRITICAL ISSUE. I
WANT TO ALSO SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR GLAZERS- FOR HIS.
PARTNERSHIP OVER THESE PAST.
FEW YEARS ON THIS REALLY.
CHALLENGING ISSUES. ONCE A
THANK YOU TO SENATOR DODD
CENTER DIED. JUST BEING CANDID
ABOUT IT IS BEING. A LEADER IN
THE LEGISLATURE ON ALL ISSUES.
RESILIENCY IN WILDFIRE. I
WANTED. CENTER NIELSEN AS ST I
HAVE WORKED TOGETHER ON MANY OF
THE ISSUES RELATED TO WILDFIRE
WILDFIRE RESILIENCY- MAKING
SURE THEY WERE ABLE TO CLEAN UP
OUR COMMUNITY SAID WHILE. AT
TIMES WE MAY NOT ALWAYS AGREE
ONE THING THAT WE CAN AGREE ON
IS. TO MAKE CALIFORNIA SAFER
AND GRATEFUL FOR ITS
PARTNERSHIP IN HIS LEADERSHIP.
AND HIS CO AUTHORSHIP ON THIS
BILL. AT THE BOTTOM. YOU HAVE A
COMMITMENT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO MEET WITH INDUSTRY.
AND THAT WITH INDUSTRY LAST
WEEK I'LL MEET WITH INDUSTRY
NEXT WEEK ON THIS BILL WE ARE
WALKING A FINE LINE. AND I'M
NOT TRYING TO BE COOLEY TO ANY
MEMBERS HERE SAYING THAT WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO UPSET THE
PRECEDING WERE REALLY TRYING TO
WALK THAT FINE LINE NO. I DID
NOT UPSET THE PROCEEDING. AND
THAT IS WHY WE ARE NOT
SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON ISSUES.
RELATED TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION BECAUSE THAT HAS
BEEN A COMMITMENT AT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. AFTER
CENTER GLAZER AND ICE BUILD
DIED LAST YEAR ON SEVENTY TWO
HOUR BACKUP. IN ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS- THE PUBLIC
UTILITY COMMISSION AND PICKED
UP THE BALL AND AN WITH IT. WE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO PUT IN THE LEGISLATURE. THAT
THERE WAS KILLED. FAST FORWARD
WE THEN HAVE ADDITIONAL OUTAGES
THIS YEAR. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
TRY TO BE A TO FIND A SWEET
SPOT ON THIS BILL AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE THIS BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER GLAZER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS RE REFER TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE
FORTY ONE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DOT BY DOT HI NELSON.
NIELSEN AYE ALLEN ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA ARTS HYPER. BAKER HI
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE HUESO HUESO AYE
JONES NO JONES NO KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ. HI MELENDEZ AYE
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
RUBIO WILK HI WELCOME BYE IT'S
TEN ONE THE BILL WOULD BE
PLACED. BOB PAUL PULL YOUR BIKE
UP TO PLEASE FORCES ARE.
BORDERS HI SO THAT'S ELEVEN
VOTES FOR ONE NO THIS BILL
PLACE BE PLACED ON CALL. WE
WILL NOW BE MOVED TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB FIVE FIVE ONE I
BELIEVE SENATOR STERN WILL BE
PRESENTING REMOTELY GOOD
MORNING SENATOR STERN YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
COMING THROUGH OKAY. COMING
THROUGH LOUD AND CLEAR OKAY
THANKS FOR THE YEAH I'M THIS.
IS IT SB FIVE FIVE INCOMES
CRUCIAL TIME MR COMMITTEE-
THINKING CHEER. HE'S
PARTNERSHIP SHE'S WORK- ONE
EXTENDERS TERM TO SO ATTORNEY.
HOUSE CENTERS. YES HOLD ON TO
YOUR YOUR COMING LOUD AND CLEAR
IN STARRY. BUT I'VE BEEN TOLD
BY A TECH X. YOU TO TURN
SPEAKER DOWN ON YOUR COMPUTER
PERHAPS. OKAY SEE HOW THAT
WORKS IF YOU COULD START OVER
I'D APPRECIATE IT. YEAH THAT'S
RIGHT AS THIS. SOUNDS GOOD SO
FAR BUT SEE IF WE CAN. BEFORE I
BEGIN. STILL LOOKING I DON'T
SEE ANY AMENDMENTS YOU'RE
LOOKING GOOD SO THAT'S A CASE
PROCEED- PROVIDING
ADMINISTRATION I THINK SAID
MORE THAN I CAN SAY- IN THEIR
INTRODUCTION TO THE AMERICAN
JOBS PLAN WHERE THEY LAID OUT.
A COMPLETELY TRANSFORMATIVE
SCOPE OF INVESTMENT IN THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE SECTOR THAT.
WE WANT TO SEE. MARCH IS DOUBLE
IN SIZE BUT INCREASED TO TEN X.
WHAT IT IS TODAY OVER THE NEXT
DECADE. THEY PUT A HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS
FORD IN THE AMERICAN JOBS PLAN
AND THIS THE GOVERNOR HIMSELF
HIS PROPOSED ABOUT A BILLION
AND A HALF DOLLARS. THERE'S A
LOT OF BUDGET ACTION PROCEEDING
HERE BUT I THINK THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS TO TRY TO GET SOME
GOVERNANCE AND STEM COHESION
AMONGST TWENTY FIVE DISPARATE
STATE AGENCIES AND ALL MULTIPLE
LEVELS OF LOCAL AND REGIONAL
GOVERNMENTS ALL ADMINISTERING
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF. OUR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE PROGRAMS AND
IF THERE'S THIS MUCH. MONEY ON
THE TABLE POTENTIALLY AND THIS
MANY SERIOUS STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ARE INTERESTED IN SEEING NOT
JUST OUR COUNTRY BUT OUR STATE
BE A GLOBAL LEADER IN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE NOT JUST LIKE YOUR
VEHICLE SALES BUT IN THEIR
MANUFACTURING IN THE SUPPLY
CHAIN PRODUCTION. LOOKING AT
ASSETS LIKE LITHIUM VALLEY OUT
INSULTING SEE ANOTHER WAYS TO
DEPLOY INFRASTRUCTURE IN THIS
ARENA WE THINK WE NEED A
CENTRALIZED AUTHORITY WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO HAVE
CENTRAL LEADERSHIP SO THE BILL
PROPOSES JUST THAT- CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ALREADY THAT
WE THINK THE TIMING MAKES
SENSE- THERE'S ALIGNMENT ACROSS
STAKEHOLDERS INDUSTRY LABOR
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS. AND
CRITICAL BRING SOME COHESION TO
AN ALREADY EXCELLENT RANGE OF
REGULATORY AND INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS AMONGST- OUR STATE
AGENCIES NOT INTENDED TO
UNDERCUT ANY OTHER AUTHORITY OR
ADD ANYTHING TO CLICK IT IF BUT
TO HAVE A CENTRALIZED FRONT
DOOR SO THAT. THE BIG PLAYERS
IN THE AUTOMOTIVE INDUSTRY AND
SUPPLY CHAIN HAVE ONE PLACE TO
GO TO A TO BUILD SOME COHERENCE
IN THIS LANDSCAPE AS WE TRY TO
BE SOMETHING TRANSFORMATIVE. I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY- MATT
PETERSON IS THE CEO OF THE L.
A. CLEANTECH INCUBATOR AS WELL
AS SPENCER READER WHOSE WITH
AUDI ADD TO PROVIDE SOME
TESTIMONY. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATE I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE I DIDN'T. HEAR
BECAUSE OF THOSE AT THE
BEGINNING DID YOU ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS YES SINCERELY
APPRECIATED IN ACCEPTING THE
COMMITMENTS THANK YOU CENTER
STERN OKAY WILL MOVED OUT I
BELIEVE- MISTER PETERSON ARE
YOU ON THE LINE YOU CAN PROCEED
IF YOU ARE. I AM. THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THAT COULD BE WITH
YOU HERE TODAY. GET YOUR
CONSIDERATION AS WE WORK FOR
SENATOR STERN TO. SHARE THE
BELIEVE WHAT IS. THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE TO LEAD AND THE
GENESIS OF THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION. COMES FROM
ORGANIZATIONS CREATION OF THE
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
PARTNERSHIP FOR UNIQUE
REGIONAL. COOPERATION OF PUBLIC
PARKS PRIVATE PLAYERS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND BEYOND
WORKING TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND AIR
POLLUTION. IN GREATER LOS
ANGELES FURTHER OUR GOALS
INCLUDE GOING 25% OF THE BEYOND
WHAT AT THE TIME WHEN WE SET
THAT TARGET WAS GOVERNOR
BROWN'S EXECUTIVE ORDER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES
BY. INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF.
WHAT VEHICLES ON THE ROAD
LOOKED TRUCKS YOUR EMISSIONS
TRUCKS IN THE CORE IN CHARGE.
AND AS LOOK AT HOW WE ACHIEVE
THOSE TARGETS FOR EXAMPLE. 30%
OF ALL THE CARS ON THE ROAD BY
THE TIME THE WAY OVER FROM
TWENTY TWO EIGHT OLYMPIC
APPAREL GAMES HERE- WE NEEDED
PARTNERS BEYOND WHAT WE HAD
CABLE GERMS OF REGION. PLAYERS
WE KNEW WE HAD LOOK AT FEDERAL
LEVEL AS STERN TALKING IN
PERSON BY THE- AMERICANS PLAN
WE HAVE A PARTNER NOW THE WHITE
HOUSE TO HELP US GET THERE WE
NEED TO WORK WITH CON. TO MAKE
SURE K. GETS MORE. DO THEY GET
SUCH SHARE- SO AS WE LOOK TO BE
ARE. WE BELIEVE CALLER COMPANY
THE- HELPS. DO THAT- AND I WILL
AT OTHER. OF WE NEEDED STATE
LAW. WE LOOK THE PILOTS AND-
THAT WE WERE. WE REALLY ROLL
THE BALL UP INTO KINDS FOR THE-
BE THE ORDER TO DO. THINGS
SENATORS. PROVIDING SHE
LEADERSHIP STRUCTURE PLANNING.
AND REALLY KIND OF BILL WHEN
NEED TO WORK THIS WHEN WE DO
AFTER. WHICH STATE A- WORK-
PRIVATE SECTOR PARTNER OR
REGIONAL PARTNERS GOVERNMENT IS
SET. SECOND OPERATE FIND GAPS
TO THE EXISTING FUN AND- TO WE
HAVE. TO HELP. ACCELERATE THIS
A WILL TREND. THIRD BUT NOT
LAST CERTAINLY NOT WE- REAL
PRIOR TO ACT. AS WELL AS
ENHANCING THE ACROSS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BUT PRIORITIES ARE
TO BE CRITICAL FAULTS AND
MAKING SURE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
IS READY FOR THIS TRANSITION
AND TRANSFORMATION. AS WELL AS
THAT WE BUILD ON THE EXISTING
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY THAT IS
REPRESENTED BY THE MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE COMPANIES THAT ARE
BUILDING NEED THESE. ASSEMBLY A
BEES THAT ARE PUTTING IN
CHARGERS. ROSS THE STATE AND
BEYOND- SO WE REALLY ARE
EXCITED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE. TO WORK TOGETHER WITH
THIS SENATE ON THE ASSEMBLY
INPUT THIS BILL IN FRONT OF THE-
WERNER WE HOPE THIS YEAR WILL
PLEASE THAT OVER SIXTY
ORGANIZATIONS OR SUPPORT THIS
BILL INCLUDING LOCAL GOVERNMENT
INDUSTRY LEADERS START UPS
BERMAN ORGANIZATIONS BARNALA
JUSTICE GROUPS PUBLIC HEALTH
ACADEMIA MORE. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I. BOTH. THANK
YOU- MISTER READER PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU SURE CAN YOU
ALL HEAR ME CORRECTLY YES.
THANK YOU AGAIN CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SPENCER READER I'M DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND
SUSTAINABILITY AT AUDI OF
AMERICA. AUDI IS A MEMBER OF
THE TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION PARTNERSHIP
HOSTED BY LACI. MATHIS
ORGANIZATIONS ALL WEEK STOOD
ALONGSIDE CALIFORNIA FOR THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF GOVERNOR
NUISANCE EXECUTIVE ORDER. AB
MORE SIGNIFICAN UNEQUIVOCALLY
SUPPORT OF THE STATE OF THE
PRIOR FEDERAL MINISTRATION
REVOKED ITS AUTHORITY TO
REGULATE VEHICLE EMISSIONS AND
PROCEEDED. WE CAN FEDERAL FUEL
ECONOMY STANDARDS. THE CREATION
OF THE CALIFORNIA VIA FORTY
WOULD BE A LOGICAL NEXT STEP TO
SOLIDIFY THE STATE'S COMMITMENT
AND FULLY OPTIMIZING THE
STRATEGY. CELERY DR GIVE ALL
THE OPTIONS AND REALLY KIND OF
FOCUSED EFFORT BEHIND THE
FUNDING PIECE OF THE STRATEGY.
OF WHICH THE CURRENT ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION REQUEST BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE'S CRITICAL. NONE OF
US INVOLVED IN THE DAY TO DAY
OF BRINGING THIS NEW
TRANSPORTATION FUTURE TRAILED
WILL TELL YOU. IT'S GOING TO BE
USING HOWEVER. IT IS ACHIEVABLE
SUFFICIENT PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
RESOURCES CAN BE MARSHALL. HOW
DO YOU INVESTING FIFTEEN
BILLION IN ELECTRIFICATION OVER
THE NEXT FOUR YEARS ALONE. WE
HAVE SIX PARKING VEHICLES IN
THE U. S. MARKET TODAY ANOTHER
ONE ARRIVING LATER THIS YEAR
TWENTY THREE ADDITIONAL MODELS
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. WE'RE
WE'RE ALL IN. WE HAVE NO DOUBT
THE STATE IS COMMITTED AS WELL
PARTICULARLY THE YOUNG MEN WORK
BEING DONE THE CARD. THE CC AND
GO BUSINESS FALLS THE OTHER
ASIANS. IN OUR VIEW THE
CALIFORNIA EASIEST ORTIZ WILL
INCREASE THE ODDS FOR SUCCESS.
AN IMPROVING THE ODDS IN THE
FACE OF COARSENING CLIMATE
IMPACTS IT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING WE THINK IS WORKING
AT. SAUDI PROBABLY. SUPPORTERS
OPEN EIGHT SIX QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU MR READER NOW WILL ON TO A
OTHER HERE IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE- IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
NOT SEEN ANYBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE EITHER- TOOK WILL MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR VERSUS- MODERATOR IF YOU
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FIVE FIVE ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO NOW. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE FIVE ONE ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CAREY
MEMBERS JENNIFER ROLE ON BEHALF
OF CREATED AND SUPPORTED SB
FIVE FIVE ONE WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH THAT
SEVEN MEN MEN AND RCOGNIZING
NEW BUSINESS MODELS IN THE EAST
BAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
FINAL GO TO IS BLIND FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORNING SURE NUMBERS MATCH
PROPERTY IN CALIFORNIA VISORS
ON BEHALF OF COOPER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IRANIANS TO EASTER WITH
THE WHITE MAN GROUP ON BEHALF
OF EAST BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXAVAR LINE OF FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
AT SHARE DODD MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KATHY LYNCH
REPRESENTING A CONSUMER GROUP
PLUG IN AMERICA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FIND TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO AND SHERMAN
DIED IN THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
LARGELY HEN WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU IN MEXICO
LINE OF FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MELISSA HI TO YOU ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OVER
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING HEIDI SAID CHOIR
DIRECTOR POLICY IT EMPOWER
INSTRUCTION PORT THANK. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS WILL
BRING HER ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NO OTHER LINE OF
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DILLON
JACK ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING STATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND AGAIN WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT WE HAVE
ONE MORE QUEUING UP. FIFTY ONE
AND THEN ZERO OF YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE FIVE ONE.
AND WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CALTRAIN ON BEHALF
OF MENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR. I THANK
YOU MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL THE SUPPORTERS WITHOUT FAL
THE SAME PROCESS- IN HERE FROM
ANY OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES THE GALLERY SCENE
DONE. IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING
NONE- AND NOW WE MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OR VISIT
OPPOSITION THE FIVE FIVE ONE
MODERATOR PLEASE- PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS. THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN REOPEN OPPOSITION
OF SB. FIVE FIVE ONE. AND WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR AND
THANKS TO ALL OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS. ANY MEMBERS WISHING TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE CENTER
ARCH ALETTA. YES THANK YOU TO
SHARE. IF I MAY ADD ASK A
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR. THIS IS
CERTAIN. YES THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN LOOKING AT THE BILL I SEE
A LOT OF REFERENCES TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND PLUG IN CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT DOES NOT DO
ANYTHING IN REFERENCE TO
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL VEHICLES.
WHILE INVESTMENTS IN BATTERY
ELECTRIC CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AFTER VALUE IN
ACHIEVING THE STAGE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION TARGETS THEY DO
NOT GET US. OUT THERE ALONE WE
NEED TO LOOK TO THE TO ADDING
ADDITIONAL OF WAY TO CLEAN OUR
AIR HYDROGEN FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ARE IN DOUBT ONLY
ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT OPTION TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU SENATORS.
WILL THIS NEW AUTHORITY ALSO
PROMOTE ELECTRIC AND HYDROGEN
VEHICLES AND IT WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO WORK WITH ME TO
AMEND YOUR BILL SO WE COULD
ALSO INCLUDE INVESTMENTS IN
ADVANCING OUR HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. I THE QUESTION
AND ALSO YOUR YOUR LEADERSHIP
CENTER TO LET IN THIS SPEECH.
I'M NOT JUST. HI GENERATE LARGE
BIG GREEN ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN
AND LOOKING AT THE PORTS. THE
REASON WE- WE DIDN'T SORT OF
FOCUSING ON HYDROGEN HERE- IN
THE STATE IT SORT OF LIGHT DUTY
FOCUSED SECTOR- THERE'S ALREADY
SOMETHING I CALL THE FUEL CELL
PARTNERSHIP ON UNDER ALL THE
UNDER THE CURRENT INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS IN THE HIGH DURING
SPACE THAT IS SORT OF THE
CENTRAL AUTHORITY FOR PLANNING.
HYDROGEN FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE
WE HAD A GOAL OF I THINK- A
HUNDRED STATIONS AT ONE POINT
AND NOW IT'S I THINK THE GOAL
HAS INCREASED SO WE ACTUALLY
WERE TRYING TO COPY THAT MODEL
A LITTLE BIT HERE FOR THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CITED DIDN'T
HAVE THAT SAME AUTHORITY. BUT
IF THERE'S A NEED TO THE
CENTRALIZER DO ANYMORE THAT
KIND OF BUSINESS INTERFACING OR
SUPPLY CHAIN WORK ON THE FUEL
CELL AND HYDROGEN SIDE I'M I'M
MORE THAN WILLING TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THAT MIGHT MY SENSE FROM
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING TO IS. THEY KIND OF HAD
THEIR ONE STOP SHOP ALREADY ON
THE HYDROGEN SIDE AND DIDN'T
WIN HERE THAT NEED AS MUCH FROM
THE STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY BUT I
I'M MORE THAN WILLING TO WORK
WITH YOU BECAUSE I AGREE
ESPECIALLY IN IN THE HEAVY DUTY
ARENA- BUT YOU KNOW. IN ALL
SECTORS I THINK WE SHOULD BE
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL IS JUST
THAT- YEAH I WE SAW THE GAP
HERE ON THE EASY SIDE WHICH. IS
WHY WE DID THE BILL THIS WAY.
SHE PARTNERSHIP ON THE FUTURE
OF A HYDROGEN I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU. GREAT
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR COMMENTS MANY MEMBER.
CENTER BACKER. THE AUTHOR THIS
IS THAT. THANK YOU THIS IS THE
KIND OF THINKING CUT EFFORT
THAT'S GOING TO BE NEEDED TO
MAKE THE GIANT LEAP FORWARD BY
THAT HE MENTIONED IN THAT MAKE
MATT PETERSON MENTIONED IN HIS
TESTIMONY I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM IN THE FUTURE
AND WITH THIS BODY TO HELP US
MAKE THIS LEAP WHICH IS VERY
MUCH NEEDED. SENATE HUESO.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE-
FROM UP BECAUSE OF IT- AND
REGARDING HYDROGEN AND THAT
WHY. IN IN EVERY POLICY. NOT
EVERY POLICY I MEAN TIME.
CALIFORNIA HAS TENDED IS TO
FAVOR ELECTRIC IN SO MANY AREAS.
BUT JOB IN I THINK IT WOULD BE
VERY PRUDENT FOR CALIFORNIA TO
THE AND I THINK THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED THIS TO BE TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
AND I THINK THERE IS SOME ROOM
IN THIS BILL TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
AND I JUST WANTED TO ECHO MY
SUPPORT IN MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION. AND AT THIS BILL
DIDN'T COME TO MY COMMITTEE AND
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC AND
BECAUSE OF THE NEW RULES.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE REVIEW OF
BILLS BUT- I THINK. THIS IS A
BILL THAT WOULD. A WARRANT SOME
REVIEW IN THIS AREA AND I JUST
WANTED TO ENCOURAGE A DIALOGUE
TO CONTINUE AS THIS PROCESS
UNFOLDS AND- THIS IS A GOOD
BILL LOVE TO SEE IT MOVE
FORWARD. AND US TO WORK
TOGETHER COLLABORATIVELY TO SEE
HOW WE CAN- EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
COURAGE OTHER TECHNOLOGIES TO
BE EMPLOYED IN CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE THE INNOVATIONS STATE AND-
INNOVATION SHOULD BE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF UP. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF PUBLIC POLICY
AND HERE. IN OUR STATE AND I
THINK WE HAVE THE TALENT
DISLODGE THE LATER CHIEF THAT
WE SHOULD PUT. OUR MINDS TO
WORK COLLECTIVELY TO ACHIEVE
THAT AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS. ADVOCACY IN IN
THIS AREA FOR SO MANY YEARS
NOW. IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE TO
WORK WORK WITH HIM IN MY
COMMITTEE. AND TO- SEE HIM
CHAMPION SO MANY WONDERFUL
ISSUES IN THIS COMMUNITY THIS
WILL BE. ANOTHER HOPEFULLY WE
COULD WORK TOGETHER TO CREATE
ANOTHER BIG VICTORY. FOR OUR
FOR OUR STATE IN THIS IN THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
CENTER STERN I HAVE ONE DOT COM
AT. WORK NOT COMMON QUESTION.
IT'S THE HYDROGEN PARTNERSHIP I
THINK IS WHAT YOU CALL THAT. IS
THAT IT LEGISLATIVELY- IT IS AT
A LEAD WAS AT A LEGISLATIVE
DECISION TO CREATE THAT. IT'S A
GOOD QUESTION HE WAS IN I KNOW
WAS IN EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH RE
AUTHORIZED. THE HYDROGEN
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM-
I THINK THE FUEL CELL
PARTNERSHIP IS ACTUALLY CALLED
OUT IN THAT LEGISLATION BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S BEEN
CODIFIED IS SORT OF A- CENTRAL
AUTHORITY IN THE SAME WAY THAT
THIS BILL WOULD SO MAYBE THAT'S
AN ISSUE WITH THAT WE CAN. WORK
WITH YOU AND CENTER TO LET IN
CENTER HUESO ON A STATE. KICK
THE TIRES THERE SO TO SPEAK IN
AND SEE IF MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO. CODIFY CENTRALIZE THAT
AS THE WORDY ESPECIALLY AS WE
LOOK TO. NEW FUNDING STREAMS SO
I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
HAVE A DRESS THE ISSUES. SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER STREET WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. WE EXPECT ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION HERE
VERY SOPHISTICATED. GROUP IS
WORKED ON THESE ISSUES FOR A
LONG TIME SO APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP AND WE WELCOME YOU
ALL INTO THE MIX HERE AND WHEN
I THINK ALSO MY JOINT AUTHORS
AND HERTZBERG FOR. HIS HELP IN
ADVANCING THIS BILL WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. I DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON SB FIVE FIVE
ONE I SEE CENTER GLAZER- IT'S
BEEN MOVED- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWO SB FIVE
FIVE ONE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE DODD. I THOUGHT I'D
NIELSEN. OF NELSON NO ALLEN. HI
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ARCHULETA AYE BAKER. BAKER HI
FORGES. STRAFFORD GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE WESSEL AYE WESSEL
AYE JONES NO JONES NO KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ NO MELENDEZ NO
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO HI RUBIO
WILK. THAT IS SEVEN- VOTES
THREE KNOWS TO BE PLACED ON
CALL. WELL NOW MOVES TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FIVE SEVEN
SIX CENTER ARCHULETA. YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER MISTER
CHAIR. DODD IT'S A AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR ALLOW ME TO
PRESENT THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS REFERENCED
IN COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ON PAGE
THREE. THIS BILL SENATE BILL
FIVE SEVEN SIX CONTINUES A
SERIES OF MORATORIUMS ON CARD
CLUB EXPANSIONS AT THE SAME
TIME ALLOWS A MODEST GROWTH.
CALIFORNIA CARD CLUBS ARE
FUNDAMENTAL ASSETS IT MANY OF
OUR LOCAL ECONOMIES IN CITIES.
SUBURBS EVEN SERVE AS THE
LARGEST SINGLE SOURCE OF TAX
REVENUE. FOR THE CITY IN WHICH
THEY'RE LOCATED. CARDROOM TAX
FUND ESSENTIAL PUBLIC IF THEY
FIND THE CENTRAL PUBLIC SAFETY
HEALTH SERVICES INCLUDING FUNDS
FOR PARKS AND WATER DELIVERY
AND TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS.
CARD ROOMS ALSO GENERATE
SIGNIFICANT EMPLOYMENT AND
SECONDARY BUSINESS ACTIVITIES
IN MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE IN DIRE NEED. SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS EXERCISED ITS
AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE MORATORIUMS
ON THE EXPANSION OF GAMING WITH
THE LAST EXTENSION OF
MORATORIUM BE PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AT TWENTY THIRTEEN.
OVER THE YEARS THE STATE HAS
ALLOWED FOR REASONABLE
INCREASES IN NUMBER OF TABLES
AT LOCAL GOVERNMENT COULD
PERMIT IN A CARD ROOM. THE
CURRENT MORATORIUM ON CARD CLUB
EXPANSIONS IS SET TO SUNSET
JANUARY. ONE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. FURTHERMORE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NOT INCREASED
THE NUMBER OF TABLES THAT MAYBE
LOCALLY APPROVED AN EXISTING
CARD CLUBS SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN. TO ENSURE STABILITY
AND TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
REVENUE OPPORTUNITIES THIS BILL
WILL EXTEND THE CURRENT
MORATORIUM TO JANUARY ONE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I'M SORRY
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT AND WILL
LAW A MODEST INCREASE ON TABLES
AT EXISTING CAR CLUBS. MORE
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW SUBJECT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT APPROVAL UP TO TWO
TABLES PER YEAR WITH A MAXIMUM
OF TEN ADDITIONAL TABLES. IN
TURN THIS WILL PROVIDE NEEDED
FINANCIAL STABILITY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT RELY ON
REVENUES FROM THE LICENSED
GAMBLING. THIS BILL REPRESENTS
A COMPROMISE BETWEEN CONTINUING
THE CARDROOM MORATORIUM AND
ALLOWING FOR A MODEST GROWTH.
FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. WITH WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE HAD MANY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CARDROOM ALLIANCE IT
ON THE PHONE IS ONE GARCIA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CITIES OF SELF
RELIANCE BOTH ARE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AND ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. PLEASE PROCEED
MISTER MANNING. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AT MANNING WITH KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
HAWAIIAN GARDENS AND THE-
CALIFORNIA COURTROOM ALLIANCE
WHICH INCLUDES- THE BICYCLE
CASINO COMMERCE- THE OAKS THE
GRAND AND- CRYSTAL CASINO SO
CLUBS IN NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN-CALIFORNIA. AND I WOULD SAY
IT'S NICE TO BE BACK INTO THE
CAPITAL TODAY- IT'S BEEN A
WHILE SO- PLEASURE TO SEE YOU
ALL- THIS BILL- DOES THREE
PRIMARY THINGS IS- SEVEN
ARCHULETA SAID FIRST THE
CONTINUES THE TWENTY FIVE YEAR
MORATORIUM WHICH PROVIDES
STABILITY TO BOTH- THE CAR CLUB
INDUSTRY AND TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO. WHOSE REVENUES
DEPEND ON THE INDUSTRY- SECONDS
THE BILL PROVIDES- MODEST
GROWTH OR- BALANCE- BETWEEN
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SEE
FAIRLY AGGRESSIVE GROWTH AND
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SEE NO
GROWTH- WE HAVE SETTLED ON TWO
TABLES A YEAR- FOR FIVE YEARS
AND TO PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE
FOR A TEN TABLE CLUB A SMALL
CLUB THAT SIGNIFICANT GROWTH
THE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. FOR A
LARGE CLUB LIKE WINE GARDENS-
IT'S ONLY 1% GROWTH A YEAR WE
HAVE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
TABLES SO THIS IS PARTICULARLY
BENEFICIAL TO THE SMALLER CLUBS
WHO HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE. TO GROW
AT ALL FOR THE LAST SEVEN YEARS.
THE AND- THE LAST THING IN IS
CONTINUE THE LEAD PRESENCE IN
THIS FIELD TO STOP RAMPANT
GROWTH OF URBAN GAMING BECAUSE
OF CONCERNS ABOUT- GAMING
IMPACT ON SOCIETY IN GENERAL
AND WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE MEASURED GROWTH AND SO
ON SOME VOTER POSE BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO UNLIMITED LOCAL CONTROL
AND RAMPANT GROWTH- SUMMER
OPPOSED BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
EITHER NO GROWTH OR THEY DON'T
WANT THE CAR CLUBS TO EXIST AT
ALL AND SO WE'RE HERE WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND THE BALANCE AND
SWEETS BY. TO KEEP THE
INDUSTRY- GROWING I WILL SAY
THE LAST THING IS THIS BILL
WILL BE PARTICULARLY HELPFUL TO
THE INDUSTRY- WHICH HAS
SUFFERED TREMENDOUSLY DURING
THE PANDEMIC- MOST CLUBS OR
DOWN AS MUCH AS 7580% UP 290%
IN REVENUE AND TO OUR OWN CLUB
IS DOWN FROM TWO THOUSAND TO
FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES SO THIS
BILL AS WELL TIME TO HELP THE
INDUSTRY- GROW INTO THE FUTURE
AS WE COME OUT OF THE PANDEMIC
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU MISTER MANNING MISTER
GARCIA GARCIA USE ME CARDS-
YOU MAY PROCEED. MORE I'M WHAT
YOU'RE INCOME MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JUAN GUARD BACK NINETY
EXECUTOR DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CITY. FOR SOMETHING
LINE STONE CARS A THIRTY
COMPRISES THE CITY THE BELL
GARDEN COMMERCE COMPTON CUTTING
HAY AND HAWAIIAN GARDENS. THE
GTA FANS IN THE PORT OF SB FIVE
SEVENTY SIX. EXPANDING THE
CURRENT MORATORIUM WILL PROVIDE
NOT ONLY THE NEEDED FINANCIAL
STABILITY CHORE GPA MEMBER
CITIES. THAT RELY UPON VITAL
REVENUE FROM LIKE AND GAMBLING.
BUT IT WILL ALSO CONTINUE OUR
STATE COMMITMENT AND SUCCESS IN
BALANCING THE NUMBER OF
GAMBLING FACILITIES OPERATED IN
OUR STATE. CARBON BASED OUR
MEMBER STATES SURVEYED BY THE
LOCAL ECONOMIC ENGINE AND
REPRESENTS OUR LARGEST SINGLE.
SOURCE OF TOTAL TAX REVENUE.
EACH REVENUES FUND S. READ ARE
THE SUCH AS THE MERGER SERVICE.
POLICE FIRE HEALTH. HOW MUCH
PROGRAM ENTER. AMONG OTHERS. ON
A LARGER SCALE CAR CARD ROOM
SERVICE REGIONAL ECONOMIC
ENGINE PLAN THEIR DIRECT
EMPLOYMENT OF NOT ONLY LOCAL
RESIDENTS. BUT OF RESIDENTS
FROM THROUGHOUT OUR REGION AND
OTHER SURROUNDING CITIES THAT
COMPREHENSIVELY NUMBER WELL
NUMBER WELL OVER TEN THOUSAND.
AS AN EXAMPLE OF THE PROFOUND
EFFECT THE STABLE CARBON
MINISTRY CREEDS ON A MEMBER
CITIES AND SURROUNDING CITIES
CONSIDER THIS. A CLOSURE AND
SUBSEQUENT LIMITATION OF
CARTONS DUE TO COVER NINETEEN.
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED THOUSANDS
OF WORKING CLASS FAMILIES WHO
LOST THEIR LIVING WAGE JOB.
DIED NEGATIVE EFFECT CONTINUES
TO THE BAY. RESIDENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY MOST OF WHOM ARE OF
COLOR CONTINUE TO SUFFER
DISPROPORTIONATELY AND MANY
STAFF MEMBERS IN OUR MEMBER
CITIES WERE LAID OFF AND LOCAL
ESSENTIAL SERVICES WERE
DRASTICALLY REDUCED. OR
ALTOGETHER ELIMINATED THE
PROPOSAL UNDER SB FIVE SEVENTY
SIX AS PRESIDENT. OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS REPEATEDLY
EXTENDED THE MORATORIUM PASSED.
AND IT WILL CONTINUE THE
STABILITY AND RELIABILITY IN
OUR CITIES AND OUR CARGO
MINISTRY THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS REPEATEDLY
SUPPORTED IN THE PAST. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. WHEN I BOUGHT
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA NOW BEGIN-
ANY OTHER WHAT HERE IN THE
GALLERY SEEING- THE- ANY
REDNESS IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. IS
IT SKEWS ME. THANK YOU SORRY
ABOUT THAT FOLLOWING PLEASE
PROCEED. THE TEAM PROVIDING
MONNING A CHEAPER SECURE
MEMBERS JIM CROMARTY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
ALREADY HAD. OR STILL IN.
SUPPORT. SO. THERE'S NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE-
NOW WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OF THIS-
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SEVEN SIX. THANK YOU AND IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE
SEVENTY SIX. SB FIVE SEVENTY
SIX. AND ONE MOMENT THERE'S A
FEW KEY ANOTHER BOOK OR LINE OF
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KILEY FOR MEETING WITH WHITE
HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF PARK WENT TO THE YOU KNOW.
THE PART OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE
LINE UP FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ORDERING MISTER MEMBERS
THISIS MEL HOSPODAR FOR
CALIFORNIA POLICY SOLUTIONS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF COMPTON
R. COSTA CASINO AND OCEANS
ELEVEN CASINO ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU CENEX TOOK A
LINE OF. THIRTY SEVEN.
MODERATOR CAN YOU CALL AGAIN
PLEASE. HEY WE MAY HAVE LOST
THE MODERATOR SO WE'RE GONNA
TAKE. A LITTLE TIME OUT HERE.
BY THE WAY HOW ABOUT BAYLOR.
WHILE WE'RE IN OUR LITTLE
MOMENT.
YEAH. YEAH LARA- I JUST
SAW. YEAH.
MEMBERS DIRT DUE TO
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WERE
GOING TO RECESS FOR TEN MINUTES.
ONE FIVE. THE SENATE GEO
COMMITTEE RETURNS FROM RECESS-
PRIOR TO- RECESSING WE HAVE A
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY- WITH-
GETTINGWITNESSES- WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MY UNDERSTANDING WE
HAVE THE MODERATOR BACK AND
MODERATOR FEW PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SEVENTY. AT FIVE THIRTY SIX YES
FIVE SEVEN SIX AT THE END
MODERATOR APPARENTLY THERE WAS
TO THE LAST TWO CALLERS WE DID
NOT HEAR SO IF POSSIBLE IF YOU
WERE ONE OF THE LAST TWO
CALLERS AND YOU'RE STILL
LISTENING. PLEASE CHECK IN. YES
YOU MAY FREAK YOU OUT BY
PRESSING ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RESISTANCE
LOOPER ON BEHALF COVERS CASINO
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SEVENTY
SIX- AND WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND CONGRATULATE THE
TRIGGER ON THE BAYLOR WILL.
THANK YOU MISTER LOPER THANK.
ENTER THE REMINDER WE ARE ON-
SB FIVE SEVENTY SIX IN SUPPORT.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
IN Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IT HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
TIM CROMARTIE AND LISA. OUR
CITY ON NICO NO ON THE
COASTLINE IS LEAD OPPOSITION MR
CROMARTIE- LET'S BEGIN WITH YOU.
MEMBERS. IMPORTING OPPOSITION
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CITIES GIVE ME A FORTY THE
CITIES OF CALL GARDENA SAN JOSE
AS WELL AS THE VENTURA.
PLAYER'S CLUB IN VENTURA
CONGRESS OF RACIAL EQUALITY OF
THE COALITION A PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICER SUPPORT SERVICES. THESE
ENTITIES RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THIS MEASURE AND SEEK
AMENDMENTS TO LEADING THE
RESTRICTION ON THE NUMBER OF
GAMING TABLES. THEY DO NOT WANT
RAMPANT EXPANSION BUT THEY DO
WHAT THE ABILITY TO MAKE THEIR
OWN DECISIONS REGARDING
BUSINESSES THAT THEY'VE
AUTHORIZED OPERATE WITHIN THEIR
RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES. WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
NOT TO VIEW THIS BILL IN A
VACUUM. BUT IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE DEVASTATING REALITYOF A
PANDEMIC NOW IN ITS THIRTEENTH
MONTH. THAT IS TRIGGERED
UNRELENTING DECLINE IN SALES
TAX REVENUES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. NEWS ON WHICH LOCALS ARE
HEAVILY DEPENDENT. THE
SITUATION IS SET LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS EVERYWHERE
SCRAMBLING FOR ALTERNATIVE
REVENUE SOLUTIONS. VIEWED
THROUGH THE LENS OF COVERT AND
ITS IMPACT ON LOCAL REVENUES.
IS MEASURES EXTREMELY HOSTILE
TO THE CITY'S CURRENTLY HOSTING
SMALL TO MEDIUM SIZE CARD. THE
REALITY IS THE CARVINGS ARE
REVENUE GENERATING ENTITIES
THIS BILL WOULD CHOKE THOSE
REVENUES OFF THE CONCLUDING
EXPANSION OR SEVERELY
RESTRICTING THE NUMBER OF TAKE
GAMING TABLES A GRANULAR
REGULATION THAN ANY OTHER
INDUSTRY. WOULD RESIDE
EXCLUSIVELY WITHIN THE PURVIEW
OF LOCAL DISCRETION AND LOCAL
POLICE POWER. THIS MEASURE IS
MORE ABOUT PERPETUATING MARKET
DOMINANCE HANDFUL OF LORD CARD
CLUBS ENTITIES ABOUT
CONTROLLING. PROLIFERATION OF
GAMBLING I THINK YOU. THANK
YOU- MISS R. CITY- KOTO PLEASE
PROCEED. HOPEFULLY I DIDN'T-
MISPRONOUNCING NAME TOO BADLY.
POLICE ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
CAROLINA'S OPEN. TWEET I KNEW
YOURSELF. ONE MOMENT. OPERATOR
WHILE YOU'RE WORKING WITH HER
I'M GONNA GO TO. GOOD YES CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE PROCEED. WONDERFUL THANK
YOU SO MUCH CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AT LEAST ARE COULD BE A CORNER
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION AS SB FIVE SEVENTY
SIX HE'S ORIGINAL ORDINANCES
WERE PUT IN PLACE MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS AGO AND HAVE
ALLOWED VERY LIMITED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MODERNIZING.
TODAY MANY JURISDICTIONS SEEKS
TO EXPAND GAMING LOCALLY BUT
ARE PREVENTED BY THIS
MORATORIUM SEVERAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE WRITTEN IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE FOR
THAT VERY REASON. THE ORIGINAL
STATE MORATORIUM WAS MEANT TO
PROVIDE A SHORT HIATUS WHILE
NEWLY CREATED REGULATORY
AGENCIES. UNDER THE GAMBLING
CONTROL ACT WERE IN THEIR
FORMATIVE STAGE. THAT LIMITED
MORATORIUM HAS BEEN EXTENDED
FROM NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT TO
CHECK THAT. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THREE AND NOW PROPOSED TO TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY EIGHT WHICH
WOULD MEAN EXPANSION FROM THREE
YEARS NOW TO THIRTY YEARS. IF
MEASURE REPRESENTS AN INTRUSION
AGAINST LOCAL AUTHORITY THAT
DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE JUSTIFIED.
MUCH OF THE ARGUMENT IN SUPPORT
IS SIMPLY THIS IS THE WAY WE'VE
ALWAYS DONE THINGS.
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES IT MAY BE
APPROPRIATE TO CHANGE THE WAY
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THINGS. WE
ARE AWARE OF NO COMPELLING
REASON HY THE CURRENT
MORATORIUM ON LOCAL EXPANSION
OF LEGAL GAMING OPERATIONS
SHOULD BE EXPANDED YET AGAIN.
REVENUE FROM THESE OPERATIONS
COULD BRING SIGNIFICANT
MATERIAL BENEFIT TO THE-
ARTICULATELY IN THE WAKE OF THE
PANDEMIC OF THE DESIRE TO GROW
REVENUES AND EMPLOYMENT AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE AND THEY OUGHT TO
HAVE THE REGIONAL REASONABLE
FLEXIBILITY TO DO SO. FOR THESE
REASONS THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES RESPECTFULLY
URGES AND THEY'LL VOTE ON THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU- I'M NOT
SEEING. ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- WILL MOVE
NOW TO- WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATE IF YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WANTED TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE SEVEN SIX. THANK YOU HERE
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SEVEN
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES I MUST HAVE BEEN
MISUSED THANK YOU FOR TAKING MY
CALL BUT I WAS GOING TO REPEAT
MY TESTIMONY FOR SUPPORT OF THE
BILL SB FIVE SEVENTY SIX. SO
AGAIN THIS IS EMMANUEL MICHAEL
EMAIL FROM STOCKS YOU KNOW IN
TRACY I APOLOGIZE IF IT'S THE
WRONG QUEUE BUT WE HAD SOME
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES TECH
DECIDE TO EAT DINNER WITH MY
STRONG SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL
AND I THINK DOCTOR FOR IT WE
ARE SMALL CARTOON THANK YOU AND
EVEN A CLOSER AND WE GOT IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE. YOU CALLING BACK
NEXT BEAKER.THANK YOU ABOUT A
LINE OF THIRTY. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M SURE MEMBERS OUT OF
CABLE MOST MACRI PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF OF BEING ONE OF ONE
CAR CLUB IN SAN JOSE WE ARE
CLOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU N.
OR ONE MORE TIME SB FIVE SEVEN
THANK. IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN- GOOD MORNING
KERR BLACKBURN ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF INGLEWOOD IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME MISTER DROUGHT THANK
YOU MODERATOR AND ALSO THANKS
TO ALL OUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WHO SHALL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS.
IS ANYBODY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. IF YOU GET YOUR
MIKE UP IF YOU COULD RAISE YOUR
HAND TO BECAUSE THE CLERK
CENTER HUESO. THANK YOU MISTER
JUST TO COMMENT ON ON THIS BILL
AND- HOW CALIFORNIA HANDLES
GAMING OVERALL I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS. AS ONE OF THE CALLERS
MENTIONED THAT OUR OUR RULES
ARE ARE SOMEWHAT OUTDATED AND
ARCHAIC- IT WITH THIS- I MEAN.
LISTENING THE TESTIMONIAL FIND
THAT IT'S VERY HARD TO FIND ANY
TWO PEOPLE AGREE ON ANYTHING
RELATED TO GAME AND- BUT-
GAMINE IS EXTREMELY EXTREMELY
LUCRATIVE BUT IT'S ALSO A VICE
AND IT'S WELL KNOWN TO HAVE
CERTAIN SOCIAL IMPACTS ARE- YOU
KNOW KNOWN TO OF. HAVE A
DELETERIOUS EFFECTS ON CERTAIN
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT OBVIOUSLY
REQUIRES ITS ITS ITS HEAVY
REGULATION- CALIFORNIA WAS
DIVIDE IS A VERY DIVERSE STATE
WE PRIDE OURSELVES OF HAVING
SUCH A DIVERSIFIED ECONOMY THAT
AGES MAKES US THE MOST
PROSPEROUS BUT STATEMENT THE
NATION. MANY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA I GUESS WOULD BE
VERY HAPPY TO SEE NEVADA STYLE
GAMING BUT THAT IS NOT
CALIFORNIA I THINK CALIFORNIA
REQUIRES. SOME LEVEL OF
MODERATION IN THIS INDUSTRY.
HOWEVER THERE'S ONE PROVISION
OF THE BILL THAT I HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH IN THE THAT
PROVIDES AT THE CITY COUNTY OR
CITY. AND COUNTIES
JURISDICTIONAL LIMIT MAY
EXPAND. TO ACCOMMODATE THE
INCREASE OF GAMING TABLES
PERCENT TO THE SECTION. AND YOU
KNOW I'M IT'S NOT THAT I'M NOT
IN A OPPOSED TO A PROCESS OF
REEVALUATING. THE AMOUNT OF
TABLES PER COUNTY BUT IT'S-
PROVIDING THAT. A CITY OR
COUNTY- MAY EXAMINE THAT AND
FOR MEANT THAT I HAVE A BIG
PROBLEM WITH THAT IN A IN A
STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA THIS DOES
SO DIVERSE. IF YOU ACTUALLY
LOOK AT A MAP OF CALIFORNIA
YOU'LL FIND. THAT WE HAVE SOME
COUNTIES THAT ARE ENORMOUS BUT
BARELY HAVE A FEW PEOPLE IN ON
SOME THAT ARE VERY SMALL.
EXTREMELY SMALL COUNTIES LIKE
THE COUNTY OF ALPINE WITH HAS A
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE.
WHOSE ENTIRE COUNTY- I MEAN
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT. OF THE
ENTIRE COUNTY OF ALPINE IS
OWNED BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THIS IS FEDERALLY OWNED LAND.
YOU TAKE THAT AND YOU COMPARE
THAT TO L. A. COUNTY. THAT IS-
A FLOW OF MODERATELY SIZED
COUNTY BUT WITH TEN MILLION
PEOPLE. OR LOOK COMPARE THAT TO
A VERY VERY SMALL COUNTY AS A
SAN FRANCISCO WITH. A SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
WITH THAT IS CURRENTLY THE MOST
DENSE PART OF OUR STATE. YOU
SEE THAT IT'S VERY HARD TO
DRAFT THE POLICY THAT- COVERS
EVERY PART OF THE STATE AND IF
YOU GIVE THE POWER TO THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO REALLY. LEAD TO A OVER
CONCENTRATION OF GAMING IN SOME
PARTS OF THE STATE VERSUS.
OTHERS IN SOME PARTS OF THE
STATE THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE CAME
IN WILL HAVE. A MORE THAN THEIR
FAIR SHARE AND I THINK. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA REQUIRES A
POLICY THAT WILL. EQUALLY
DISTRIBUTE. GAMING OR AT LEAST
TO FIND A WAY TO ACTUALLY.
MINIMIZE ITS NEGATIVE IMPACT
AND MAXIMISE ITS ECONOMIC
BENEFIT I THINK THERE'S A WAY.
TO DO THAT AND WE HAVE A DOUBLE
TIER SYSTEM I WAS HERE LAST
TIME WE- ADVANCE THIS AND- AND
IT JUST SEEMS THAT EVERY SINGLE
TWO OR THREE OR FOUR YEARS WERE
KICKING THE CAN DOWN. THE ROAD
ON ON. EXAMINING HOW ARE STATE
ISSUES THESE LICENSES HOW WE
TREAT GAMING- WHEN IT COMES TO
THE TRIBES THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
COME INDIVIDUALLY AND GET A
COMPACT TO VERY EXPENSIVE AND
DIFFICULT PROCESS THAT REQUIRES
LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL. AND AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL THEY'RE THEY'RE
SUBJECT TO THIS PROCESS WHICH
SEEMS TO BE. STATUS QUO YEAR IN
YEAR A YEAR AFTER YEAR AND- I
THINK THIS BILL- I THINK IT'S
AN IMPORTANT BILL IT'S AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE I THINK IT
NEEDS TO MOVE FORWARD I'M GONNA
SUPPORTED TODAY. BUT OF I HATE
TO OVERBURDEN THE AUTHOR AND
ASK HIM TO COMPLETELY REDESIGN.
THE PROCESS BUT AT LEAST IN
THIS BILL WE SHOULD ADD A
PROVISION THAT- THE- AS FOR A
STUDY TO RE EXAMINE HOW WE
APPROVE GAMING CALIFORNIA AND
IF IT'S GOING TO INCREASE IT
SHOULD INCLUDE THE THAT THE I
DON'T THINK THE GAME ROOM
SHOULD BE TREATED INDEPENDENTLY.
OF THE TRIBES IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY'RE APPROVED AND HOW THEIR
AUTHORIZED BECAUSE AS- AS WE'VE
UP SEEING HOW WE APPROVED
GAMING HERE THERE IS AND THERE
JUST SEEMS TO BE ONE PROCESS.
FOR THE TRIBES AT ANOTHER
PROCESS FOR THE GAME AND FISH
WHICH I THINK IS JUST PATENTLY
UNFAIRNESS IS BASED ON. THE
STATE'S. HISTORY OF TREATING
PEOPLE SEPARATELY ON THE SPARE
LEE. AND ANOTHER UNEQUALLY AND
I THINK WE SHOULD LOOK AT THIS
INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE AND IT
REALLY EVALUATE ITS IMPACT ON
THE STATE AND WHETHER CERTAIN
AREAS ARE HAVE AN OVER
CONCENTRATION OR NOT. AND I
JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS THAT NOW
LOOKING AT THIS BILL HOPEFUL
HOPING. THROUGH THE AUTHOR IN
THIS AUTHORS COMMITTEES
PRESENCE WE COULD PROVIDE MORE
INPUT INTO THIS BILL INTO THIS
PROCESS. THAT ONE THAT THAN
WHAT WE'RE CURRENTLY IS ON THE
TABLE. THANK YOU AT CENTER
HUESO JUDGES WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT- IT'S A FEDERAL PROCESS
THAT OUTLINES HOW WE DEAL WITH
TRIBES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. A. N. THESE BILLS-
YOU KNOW OUR- INTERESTING THAT
COME BEFORE US ALREADY SINCE
I'VE BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE
SIX. YEARS I THINK THIS IS THE
THIRD EXTENSION WE'VE SEEN SOME
SHORT EXTENSIONS NOW WE'RE
SEEING A WHOLE LOT LONGER
EXTENSIONS. BUT IT'S A BALANCE
BETWEEN SMALL CARD ROOMS MEDIUM
SIZE LARGE IT ALSO THE NEEDS
AND WANTS OF THE TRIBES AND
ALSO THE NEEDS OF THE WANTS OF
PEOPLE THAT DON'T WANT. ANY
GAMBLING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CENTER HUESO BACK TO
YOU. I DO APPRECIATE THAT
CLARIFICATION I THINK WAS VERY
NECESSARY BUT I JUST WANTED TO
PUT MY COMMENTS IN THE CONTEXT
OF WHAT YOU SAID BURIED IN MIND
THAT THERE ARE FEDERAL LAWS AND
ALSO STATE LAWS. THERE SHOULD
BE A WAY OF INCLUDING. AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA INTO CERTAIN EITHER
METROPOLITAN OR STATISTICAL
AREA METROPOLITAN STATISTICAL
AREAS TO CAPTURE. THE AMOUNT OF-
POPULATION IN THOSE AREAS TO
REALLY EVALUATE. AND BEARING IN
MIND THAT THERE ARE OTHER RULES
THAT COULD BE INCLUDED IN THE
OVERALL STATE POLICY. TO
REGULATE GAMING ACROSS THE
STATE IN A WAY THAT'S THAT'S
EQUITABLE WE COULD STILL.
DETERMINE THAT CONSIDERING
FEDERAL LAWS THAT EXIST THANK
CENTER HUESO CENTER ALLEN DID
YOU HAVE. I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY
ELSE COMMITTEE. SEEING THAT
THERE ARE NO OTHER- COMMENTS-
CENTER ARCHULETA WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YEAH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. OKAY WITH THAT DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON IT S. B. FIVE
SEVEN SIX AT CENTER HUESO MAKES
THAT MOTION- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS A MINUTE BUT FIRST AMENDED
RE REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE
ITEM THREE SB FIVE SEVENTY SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD. DODD AYE
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE ALLEN
AYE ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE
ARCHULETA AYE BAKER. BY BAKER I
BORDERS. BRADFORD GLAZER. HI
GLAZER AYE WHY SO Y. MYSELF AYE
JONES. KAMLAGER MELENDEZ
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO HI RUBIO
WILK. THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES
WILL PLACE THE BILL ON CALL.
OKAY MEMBERS NOW WILL OPEN UP
A- LOT MORE DURING IF WE SHOULD
WAIT ONE MINUTE FOR A- CENTER
MULLIN. LET'S SEE WHO NEEDS TO.
YEAH CAN WE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND GET IN HERE.
PLEASE- YEAH I THINK.
OKAY
SENATOR KAMLAGER AND SENATOR
BRADFORD OR IN THE HOUSE. SO MR
SECRETARY CAN WE- GO THROUGH
THE ROLE ON EVERY BILL WILL
FIRST BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB THREE FORTY ONE
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE PLEASE OPEN
UP THE ROLE ON SB. THREE FORTY
ONE. HE NEED TO MIGHT. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE FORTY
ONE ABSENT MEMBERS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
RUBIO. THAT'S THIRTY ONE
SHERMAN S. THIRTEEN EYES ONE
KNOW THAT BILLS OUT NOW WILL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
FIVE FIVE ONE BY SENATOR STERN
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
ON FIVE FIVE ONE THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWO SB FIVE FIVE ONE CHAIR
VOTING I BY SERVING NO ABSENT
MEMBERS BORDERS. BRADFORD
BRADFORD HI KAMLAGER KAMLAGER
ALL RIGHT RUBIO WILK. WILK HI.
EXTENDED RETIREMENT THAT IS TEN
IS THREE KNOWS THAT FILLS OUT
WILL NOW MOVE THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE ESPYS FIVE SEVEN
SIX BY CENTER ARCHULETA
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
ON SB FIVE SEVEN SIX THIS IS
FILE ITEM THREE SB. FIVE
SEVENTY SIX ABSENT MEMBERS
GORGEOUS BRADFORD. BRADFORD
EFFORT HI JONES KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I MELENDEZ RUBIO WILK.
WELL NO. THAT'S TWENTY ONE
SHERMAN. THAT'S TEND TO WHAT
WITH BRADFORD VOTING HI. TEN
FIVE ONE NO. THE BILL IS OUT OF.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TORE COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORD THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
FOR ALL YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA MODERATOR THANK YOU
THANKS ARE SO THAT ARE HERE
TODAY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION IS A
JERK. WHO.